[Musique]
de gaulle qui voulait attendre le plus
tard possible s'est égaré un mois avant
le premier tour c'est très court à ce
jour c'est même le délai le plus bref
jamais enregistré pour un présent la
république 31 jours exactement entre le
4 novembre qui de surcroît était la
saint-charles et le 5 décembre premier
tour delà de la présidentielle avec le
recul c'était une stratégie risquée
puisque de gaulle qui ne se déclarait
pas parce qu'ils pensaient tout
simplement que sa réélection était en
quelque sorte une formalité et bien a eu
la surprise de se retrouver mis en
ballottage au premier tour il l'a mal
vécu au point qu'il avait même été tenté
de se retirer la compétition entre les
deux tours
incontestablement cette ce retard ou en
tout cas cette mise en ballottage est le
fruit d'une campagne beaucoup trop
tardive là au contraire ses challengers
ont joué la carte de la nouveauté et de
l'intérêt de l'opinion pour une
compétition nouvelle
[Musique]
valéry giscard d'estaing semble ne pense
n'avoir aucun rival et il choisit assez
naturellement de rester protégé par sa
fonction de président le plus longtemps
possible ce qui fait que lui aussi va se
déclarer assez tardivement ce sera le 2
mars 1981 soit 55 jours avant le premier
tour il fait sa déclaration depuis
l'elysée mais tout en disant je ne serai
pas un président candidat je serai un
citoyen candidat pensant ainsi se mettre
au même niveau que ses concurrents et
engager une véritable campagne la
campagne a duré un mois un mois et demi
en conséquence et elle a coïncidé avec
ce moment où précisément le président
sortant qui était protégé par son statut
et par sa popularité a commencé à
baisser dans les sondages baissent dans
ce sondage de popularité d'abord
sondages d'intentions de vote ensuite
jusqu'à on le sait à être battu au
second tour par françois mitterrand
[Musique]
parce que son premier ministre est en
difficulté dans l'opinion françois
mitterrand fait un double choix celui
d'entrer en campagne très tardivement et
d'entretenir une sorte de suspense de
faux suspense car on sait bien qu'il s'y
prépare mais il instille le doute dans
l'opinion ce qui fait que sa candidature
semble d'abord appelée de l'extérieur
souvenez vous c'est le moment où un
centre d'artistes comme le chanteur
renaud ou d'autres lancent campagne en
disant tonton ne nous laisse pas béton
il ya donc un appel à mitterrand
mitterrand entretient le mystère et il
va attendre le 23 mars 1988 là encore
comme de gaulle un mois seulement avant
le premier tour de gaulle c'était 31
jours avant le premier tour françois
mitterrand ce sera trente deux jours
seulement mais donc le choix d'une
campagne éclair sa position confortable
dans l'opinion lui a permis de mener
cette campagne éclair évidemment
victorieuse à l'arrivée
[Musique]
le président jacques chirac a toujours
été ce qu'on a appelé un animal
politique comprend que s'ils restent
ainsi enfermé à l'elysée il risque de
rater ce rendez vous est un peu par
surprise il décide de se déclarer plus
tôt que prévu il le fera le 11 février
du miel 2002 en marge d'un dépassement
naturellement prévu à avignon et là de
manière faussement improvisé en fait
soigneusement préparé la maire d'avignon
marie-josée rouag lui dit sur un ton
badin à monsieur le président tout le
monde se demandait ce que bout serait ou
non candidat eh bien à mon tour je vous
pose cette question et l'as partant d'un
grand éclat de rire jacques chirac lui
répond chère marie josée roy gh oui je
suis candidat il fait le choix d'une
certaine banalisation de déclarations de
campagne ça n'est pas solennellement
dans son bureau de l'elysée mais dans le
cadre d'un déplacement en province qu il
le fait
[Musique]
nicolas sarkozy comme mme chirac avant
lui est aussi une bête de campagne il
sait que sa force cette capacité
d'entraînement sa capacité de
mobilisation n'a pas cité à se
confronter des adversaires donc plutôt
que d'attendre le dernier moment comme
il l'avait imaginé au début et choisit
lui aussi de se déclarer plus tôt que
prévu il le fera le 15 février 2012 on
est dans un autre
durée assez voisin de celui de jacques
chirac en 2002 ce que jacques chirac lui
a laissé avignon nicolas sarkozy le fera
de manière plus classique en venant sur
le plateau du journal de 20 heures de
tf1